how does it feel to be here at MSM
comic-con meeting all of your London
fans awesome very exciting yeah they're
all really nice everybody we've met has
been really nice this is like my
favorite city in the world and my I
guess second time at London Expo but
it's my favorite trip of year by far so
it's good to be back and when you do get
a chance to meet fans one of the most
common questions you get asked about the
show lady characters that's actually
funny to me that you really do get asked
like the same questions over and over um
I get uh when is Big Jim gonna die a lot
um I got who is oh my god I can't even
tell you how many times I got who's the
fourth hand when that was all in
question um basically just like
character questions normal self why is
Melanie all over every guy my main one
is where are you and what kind of mom
are you that you let nori just go about
the world and where are you and I'm like
you know she's always been an
independent kid I guess I mean obviously
there's a huge fan base for the show
around the world why do you think the
show has had that impact why do you
think people are connected with the
series so much because there are all
these different characters and that
people can see themselves in and there's
a situation that's applicable and
attachable for anyone anywhere if you're
put in a scenario where you can't find
your way out anybody can can can you
know pretty much connect to that kind of
scenario and find themselves you know
trying to figure it out with everyone
else in the cast and kind of see
themselves peeling away and getting
frustrated in the situation and
following love in the situation and
coming up with bright ideas that are
maybe are not so bright ideas in the
situation you know so I think there's
that element of it I think it's
definitely different and it that's why
it's intriguing to people I also think
we have a lot of names that are attached
to it that grab attention Jack bender
Dean Norris Stephen King
I think a lot of our fan base I think
began with people saying oh Stephen King
like I love Stephen King because who
doesn't and I think they kind of saw
well here's his next adoption and and it
was different that it was going to be on
TV as like a regular series and so it
was cool to kind of have him on board
and I think that really has benefitted
us as a cast and as a show so yeah what
I'm in the favorite moments Neil
characters and the latest shine in the
second season I love when I get to fight
with Mackenzie it's so fun we're like
best friends in real life so to get to
pretend to fight with each other
that's it was kind of hard not gonna lie
like I thought I was like it was not
easy look at her and try be mad at her
what happening yeah I'm trying to think
because you guys it's finished our
season two is finished in the u.s. so
I'm trying to think of where you guys
are at right now because there's a lot
of stuff in the finale for nori that was
some of my favorite stuff to do
I wonder there was one scene where I got
to do a stunt where I almost fall off a
cliff there was a scene where I got to
do a stunt and so I kind of got to work
with our stunt team a little more than
usual and like I love doing stuff like
that so that was fun the finale was so
much fun and unit anytime that you can
get most of the cast together working
together like on the same day or doing
the same we kind of all shootings
together and the scenarios are so
intense but yet between each take it's
like the funniest moments in life and
then it's like action and we're looking
at this big wall of nothing man yet it's
like the most intense moment of our life
because it's like are we gonna make it
into freedom are you know is this going
to be over or are we just looking at a
piece of tape on a camera a shocking
thing was done finale would would you
like the theater on Devon I mean being
in Chester's build it's long I'm sure we
the love
you like to spin up show even there's
just a one month episode to finish up it
would be Project Runway except for I
would be the only judge nor II would
judge all the Chester's Millers and
Melanie and Carolyn would win and Joe
and Big Jim would lose for sure what
would you like something happened in the
season after season 2 season 3 there are
so many different ways that they could
go with it so for me personally I think
it would be really cool to see just
where everyone has gone through so much
being under the dome I think it's
interesting to see like the aftermath of
all the trauma that everyone goes
through but kind of what that does to
people I think that would be interesting
to see oh my god tell the story about
the shoes man the fish fillet you create
this image of Steve at least I did do
you read these books and you create this
image of the fire this amazing sort of
iconic author in your mind and you know
and you attach all of these amazing
profound characteristics to this person
and then you meet the person of the day
with them literally at the end of like I
remember when shooting day he was
driving home with transportation and he
was like can we pull into McDonald's I
just want to fish the lane meal and it's
the first time I met him I was with
Ayesha
it was the first time I met Aisha - and
and we walked out I was like oh my god
it's him okay together it's fine we'll
just meet him it's good and I walked out
and he looks at me he goes I like your
slippers pink Thanks
and the best one he was our other the
one woman who played my wife she was
working out incessantly every morning in
the gym and we were all gym rats you
know in the beginning of the production
and so he too was in the Chairman so he
was in the gym one day and then the next
day we didn't see him in the gym and so
we saw him on set and we were like hey
so you weren't in the gym just making
you know some chat so when you were in
the gym today and he was like oh no I
was telling me I was down there so she
was so I was like oh yeah so so yeah
this amazing amazing profound prolific
writer is pretty down-to-earth and
pretty funny pretty funny we have some
breaking news last time you guys were
here with under the dome and you
announced that Stephen King was going to
write the first episode for season 2 can
we expect something similar for season 3
have you come back with a similar plan
um it's very new at that point we had
been renewed since we had been shooting
we got renewed during the shooting
process of the finale of season 1 and
this year it was about two weeks ago
maybe that we just got the official pick
up so a lot of things are still in the
works but he's been very involved season
1 and season 2 so I think you know we're
hopeful he'll still be around of course
and but as far as writing an episode we
don't know yet I guess I mean obviously
talking about stephenie's fantastic
character I'm curious apart from your
own who each of your favorite characters
on the show Oh God Big Jim because I
love Dean Norris one of the first times
we talked
I was actually crying look he probably
thinks I'm a freak I love him so Big Jim
for sure um this is kind of out of the
ordinary I really liked Dwight Yoakam
character oh because I grew up and I
watched the movie Slingblade with my dad
and I remember being like he's great
like he's so good and then he came on
our show and there hasn't been a few
times where during a scene I have just
not been able to hold it together
because I'm just hysterically laughing
and there were several times I just
couldn't do it and he does such a
phenomenal job as Lyle
and I just thought his character was
very intriguing so I don't know I was
very interested any time he had scenes I
might be biased but when my favorite
character was as nore like I think she
has the best dialogue ever under the
dome
I think anything she said you're always
like then I'm like oh god I'm
responsible for having raised her but
she has the best seems like anything she
says you know that it could be really
left feel and so it just it adds a humor
under the dome that I think is necessary
and such a stink miss that just tickles
me oh my god what was that one we were
all in the house watching that day oh
and it was you will buy the locker with
grace yes oh oh is this it oh the
safecracker like she opens the lockers
you think that whole speech when we
first of all we were excited for that
episode because we knew it was going to
be the one we're like it went now and
she was like moving in on Joe and like
so we have feeling it was like coming so
I remember opening that page like I'd
like I saw it I was like oh my god
that's so fun I mean obviously is a
really fun set I'm curious I mean you
mentioned like some of the experience
you've ever Stephen in
the filming would have been the funniest
stuff has happened oh my god well Dwight
um he will just add in random things
that are not scripted um I don't know
you tell it because I was being passed
out okay
so there's a scene basically where
Melanie is sick and we're all like
literally every single person is like on
the way somewhere and so we walk through
the school and we're walking through the
hallway and Lyle is standing on the
corner like she's like standing there
and he had a scripted line that was it's
a great day to do something wonderful
that was scripted but she had it was
like a medical center that's high school
it's turning to a medical center he had
some Neosporin man he's so wrapped it
off of a table or something yeah like
you know it was robbed and so Dean's
line in response to that was don't touch
my family and so he walks and he goes
we're all walking by and goes it's a
great night it was something wonderful
and Dean touch my family goes neosporin
and we were just like Oh like they went
back and forth for a minute and by the
time they like finally had Thomas saw I
don't know a lot of stuff happens on set
that's funny but I feel like half of it
is only funny because we're all like
deliriously tired okay so a lot of times
it doesn't seem funny to other people
but it really is funny yeah yeah there
was one time she dropped her salami
there's like they bring trays around and
then she thought the camera was gonna be
on her and so I like all the time just
here like a slap and she's just like
threw her salami on the ground because
she thought I was gonna be in the shot
yeah there was a time whenever Alex the
guy who plays junior we had a scene
together and they were getting just his
coverage and so I was like not in the
shot or anything but I was still there
delivering my line so you know help his
performance and so I'm supposed to walk
out of the scene but they're all these
crew guys so I couldn't move but I
thought okay well I'm supposed to leave
the scene right now so if he can't see
me then that'll help his performance
it'll make it more like it's real but I
couldn't move so I said my like my last
line was like okay bye so I go okay bye
he like holds it together and then as
soon as they say cut he's like I'm gonna
kiss method acting right I take it very
seriously okay on the show the big
mystery is what is the AG and what the
dumb comes from do you have your own
personal so like concept or idea of what
it is god that's a big question yeah you
kind of go through so many machinations
and trying to figure it out like I
remember the first year like I was like
oh I got this this is this is spiritual
this is like an analogy for spirituality
and I was like oh that doesn't stand up
okay
this is science it's all science this is
an analogy for theories I'm like I'm
just waiting for it like explain this to
me and like season two grace and I and
we could honestly it's kind of similar
to how you guys watch it you watch it
every week we'd get a new script every
week so it's sort of like we were
watching it but obviously not but
literally we get a script and I'd call
grace or guys would call me and we'd be
on the phone for two hours being like
well I think by this they're trying to
like lead up to like you know like Big
Jim and Nora getting together like it
was go so we talked for so long than to
be like what am I even saying that's
ridiculous it's like that's not
happening but it's we what's like
sometimes people don't realize is when
we get the script we are trying so hard
to figure out where everything is going
that by the time people like what do you
think it is we're just like so funny
because you have conversations with the
creators and writers and you're like
yeah but like you know that butterflies
mean this right and they're like sure
why not and I'm like but wait but the
dome like it it's sort of reminiscent of
and they're like yeah we haven't quite
you know we haven't committed to that
yet and I'm like well what have we
committed to
what is giving you confidence that they
know you know what it is I think they
know what the end is yeah but that's
what I think is another thing about our
show that like because a lot of times
shows have outlines for seasons and
seasons and seasons and so they know
like pretty much what they're gonna do I
think like our team of writers and our
team of creators is really going off of
partially what the audience thinks
partially what they like end up just
coming up with and that's why I think
first season the second season have been
so successful it's it's just ideas that
like people just start like where did
that come from at all and so I think
they know but I think they're going to
keep it to themselves until they know no
it doesn't help cuz like you said you
get your script once a week they know
you're learning as you go along does it
help as an actor not known what's
happening how to turn that character
because they knew life you wouldn't know
what's going on yes those are pazzo how
does it help you not know much hopefully
as you make it work in the dark because
like you say in real life you don't
really know what's going to happen so it
sort of makes your reactions to the
situation a little bit more organic I
think you know and then you're able to
have the genuine confusion about a
situation and come up with genuine
feelings and reactions to the situation
sort of more in the moment for for for
what's happening as opposed to like you
know having all of this information and
the worst thing we can do as actors is
overthink and plan I'm gonna do here
touch my Mac has a big story you've been
extremely confused and one episode about
what the script has said and then he
wouldn't consider got the conclusion of
what that might be
I never even thought that we've got
happened what servers have been any of
you a story like that
yeah I thought I had it all figured out
and then it turned around to be like no
that's not what's happening here
there's a character I don't know if you
guys have met him yet over in the UK but
some of you obviously have hunter that's
played by Max Eric I remember reading
his character and thinking one thing and
then as the scripts progressed thinking
another and then really realizing what
he actually was and now I'm kind of just
scared to commit to that because it's
probably not right either so
you